ans sur public sénat
[Musique]
marine le pen la présidente du front
national est l'invité de preuves par 3
en association avec l agence france
presse à dailymotion bonsoir madame le
pen
merci d'être avec nous vous affichez en
cette rentrée vos ambitions en ironisant
sur l'obsession que vous êtes devenu
dites vous pour l'ump pour le parti
socialiste
le psychodrame fillon votre main tendue
sous la forme d'une charte pour les
élections municipales votre banalisation
dans l'opinion alors que le chef de
l'état met en garde contre l'abandon des
valeurs héritées de notre histoire et
des principes fondamentaux de la
république nous occuperons durant cette
émission pour laquelle me rejoindre aura
fait leur mano de l' agence
france-presse
et perrine tarneaud de public sénat
d'abord le retour apparemment dû ni-ni
l'ump réaffirment à l'occasion d'un
bureau politique qui n'est pas question
d'appeler à voter pour un candidat fn et
vous renvoie à votre extrémisme et votre
sectarisme que répondez-vous à fillon
copé d'avoir un très objectivement ça
hein tu as assez peu je ne cache pas
parce que je pense que les partis
politiques concourent à l'expression des
différents courants de pensée
or j'ai le sentiment que les partis
politiques aujourd'hui ne pense qu'à une
chose c'est comment mettre en place des
tactiques politiciennes pour se faire
réélire on sait même plus pourquoi ils
veulent être réélus d'ailleurs parce
qu'il parle plus du tout de politique
c'est leur problème c'est pas le mien ça
nous a quand même si on se dit qu'ils
font aussi vos affaires m'intéresse pas
pour une raison simple si vous laissez
qu'ils sont en train de débattre autour
de la mort c'est front républicain il
c'est la veillée funèbre du front
républicain
certains disent à lui un front
républicain certains disent que c'est
une équipe qui est morte aujourd'hui par
exemple c'est jean louis borloo l'a dit
mais qu'est ce qu'un jugement mon porte
aujourd'hui sur le chacun tire un peu la
couverture à lui monsieur borloo rêve
que de pouvoir de profiter d'un petit
bout
non mais moi je n'ai pas besoin de tout
cela moi je porte un projet aux français
ils sont d'accord avec moi ou ils sont
pas d'accord ils jugent ceux qui nous
ont gouvernés
s'il juge que ceux qui nous ont
gouvernés ne n'ont pas répondu à leurs
préoccupations et bien ils regardent
l'offre qui existe l'offre qui existe
c'est celle du front national dont je
pense qu'il correspond dans le projet
qu'il veut mettre en oeuvre à ce que les
français attendent alors nous les choses
sont claires ne faut pas d'accord avec
l'ump ne font pas eu d'accord avec le
parti socialiste nous avons pourrait par
exemple pour les municipales une charte
aura plus tard nous sommes prêts à
accueillir des patriotes de droite et de
gauche sur des engagements politiques
voilà et je pense qu'en faisant cela ils
bien nous remettons un grand p à la
politique là où manifestement il ne
l'écrivent plus qu'avec un peu de ça
c'est que vous estimez remporté une
victoire idéologique quand des ténors de
l'ump déplace à droite parfois très
adroite leur curseur quand on les entend
par exemple sur l'immigration oui le
droit du sol
oui incontestablement résister cette
victoire et delaunay incontestablement
ce sont des victoires idéologique
puisque c'est nous qui avons contribué à
obliger les partis politiques pas
seulement d'ailleurs de l'ump mais
également du ps à venir sur des
thématiques telles que le
protectionnisme tels que l'existence de
frontières t que la maîtrise des flux
migratoires sur les questions
économiques votre programme dont
j'entends j'entendais vous verrez
pendant la campagne européenne
ils ne manqueront pas de venir vous
parler de l'europe protectrice concept
tout à fait nouveau dans leur bouche
ils ne manqueront pas d'évoquer la
nécessaire souveraineté de la france
après en avoir vidé totalement le
contenu je n'ai absolument aucun doute
sur le fait que nous serons la force
d'attraction notamment aux européennes
et que vous retrouverez dans la bouche
d'un certain nombre qu'ils soient de
droite ou de gauche des formulations
très proches de celles qui sont
exprimées par leurs fondations
on verra on parler d'aidé européenne
vous pensez votre objectif est d'arriver
en tête
oui c'est notre objectif je crois que
c'est une hypothèse qui est parfaitement
crédible parce qu'encore une fois l'ump
et le ps vont avoir la pire des
difficultés pendant ces élections
européennes c'est d'essayer de montrer
une divergence entre eux et pour eux ce
matin 2017 est ce que nicolas sarkozy a
raison de penser c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'il dit apparemment qu'il est le seul
à pouvoir faire barrage à votre
progression
je ne sais pas je ne crois pas que
nicolas sarkozy reviendra mais tout ça
me paraît loin est loin loin dans le
temps ça paraît moins système de vote
dans les temps mais surtout loin des
préoccupations pour l'instant des
français non je crois que vous vous
trompez le sens de mon discours à
marseille n'était pas 2017
c'était de tracer une perspective
politique aux français d'arrêter
justement de faire de la politique à la
petite semaine qu'est ce qu'on va faire
la semaine prochaine ou dans un mois
c'est une perspective française où
allons-nous voilà ce que je veux montrer
aux français et pas qu'est ce qu'on va
négocier dans les trois mois qui
viennent alors au soir de votre discours
donc à marseille lors de son université
d'été françois hollande a rappelé la
nécessité de digues pour préserver at il
dit les principes fondamentaux de la
république et arrêter notre histoire est
ce que avec vous nous cesserions d'être
fiers de nos valeurs fiers de nous mêmes
pour le dit françois hollande mais tout
ça est extrêmement vague d'ailleurs
jamais de manière précise ces j'en
explique en quoi le front national se
mettrait hors des valeurs de la
république
moi je suis pour une république une et
indivisible je suis donc à ce titre
contre le communautarisme contre la
discrimination positive
je suis pour la démocratie auquel front
national se soumet avec un grand
enthousiasme d'ailleurs en toutes
circonstances une vraie démocratie russe
que traduit ce que je suis mais bien
entendu pour le pour la proportionnelle
et je suis pour le référendum
d'initiative populaire c'est-à-dire le
la plus aboutie
des démocraties la bd également commune
faut pouvoir et bien vous ne ferez pas
plaisir à certains à l'anti doit avoir
peur
eh bien ceux qui abusent voilà ceux qui
abusent du système c'est qu'il ne
respecte pas la loi ce qui viole nos
valeurs ce qu'ils veulent imposer leur
mode de vie aux français ceux qui
fraudent et qui met en danger notre
modèle social
ceux qui se comportent comme des rapaces
comme c'est le cas par exemple pour la
grande finance et pour la banque
oui à cela effectivement je lave jules
jeu l'annoncent je ne le ferais
probablement pas plaisir mais ça tous
les partis s'accordent à dire qu'il faut
combattre les abus dont on attend droite
à gauche se sont prononcés sont pas si
longtemps mais on ne voit pas beaucoup
sauf qu'avec moi on va le voir
voilà c'est à dire que j'ai entendu mon
monsieur hollande dire qu'ils allaient
lutter contre la grande finance j'ai
rien vu un
je n'ai rien vu venir je n'ai pas vu la
célébration au niveau européen vous
connaissez le monde on a essayé de
maintenant que de régulation sur les
marchés financiers mais non à l'origine
de l'acné est sûr que non je ne
reconnais pas la première des choses à
faire était d'ailleurs de séparer les
banques de dépôt et des banques
d'affaires
en réalité ce a accouché d'une souris
et rien n'a été fait en ce domaine alors
voilà encore une fois moi je ferai ce
pourquoi j'aurais été élu alors à propos
de l'europe puisqu'on en parle mais
j'aimerais connaître votre réponse
maintenant au président de la commission
josé manuel barroso qui a dénoncé le
populisme tous les populismes de gauche
comme de droite at il dit mais elle vous
visez vous qui fait de l'europe et de
l'euro le bouc émissaire et il estime
que vous proposez des solutions
simplistes à des problèmes complexes
pourquoi c'est ce que le monsieur
barroso il défend un système que je que
je combats par conséquent c'est pas très
étonnant qui viennent sur ce terrain là
c'est quoi le populisme c'est le
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple et
pour le peuple on avait compris que
monsieur barroso est un adversaire
déclarée des pubs dans son esprit c'est
ridicule et les as qu'il tient dans le
plus grand mépris
c'est si vrai d'ailleurs que on n'écoute
pas ce que les peuples disent on les
ruines ont les pille et de surcroît
quand il s'exprime par référendum
eh bien on se débrouille avec nos
services
deux élus députés sénateurs pour venir
contredire la volonté populaire donc
comme monsieur barroso soit l'ennemi des
peuples
ça m'étonne pas qu'il atteint qu'à celle
qui défend le peuple ne m'étonne pas
long petit chat est dans la droite ligne
sans difficulté de ce qui se passe
depuis des années alors vous avez évoqué
les faux ni les marchés financiers il ya
un instant marine le pen comme étant à
l'origine note de la crise
il ya également le l'endettement lors
des demandes et pays savent où le
reconnaissait l endettement des pays
je suis ronde et non non non mais de
messieurs pierre d'euros pour la france
par exemple oui tiens c'est d'ailleurs
au passage notre endettement va
s'aggraver non parce que toutes les
politiques d'austérité visant à réduire
le déficit non seulement elle ne réduit
pas mais comme d'ailleurs c'était
prévisible puisque c'était cas en grèce
était le cas en espagne ou au portugal
cette politique d'austérité elle aggrave
les déficits et donc elle la grave la
dette est ce que les français savent que
sur ces 9 mai 1950 milliards parce qu'on
va arriver à 5 95 % du pib en 2014
il ya 1500 milliards d'intérêts que nous
avons versé aux banques depuis 1973
ça je pense que c'était un peu le noeud
gordien sur lequel personne ne veut
intervenir des prêts à alourdir
l'endettement de combien de milliards
d'euros mais puisque en sortant de
l'euro évidemment il y aurait une
dévaluation ça coûterait cher
non messieurs non je crois que vous à
chaque fois d'ailleurs il ya un pan de
notre projet que vous omettez totalement
d'indiquer aux français c'est que le
retour à la monnaie nationale
permettrait certes d'avoir une monnaie
qui ne soit pas surévaluer comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui et donc chacun
s'accorde même monsieur moscovici c'est
pour dire à dire qu'elle est un des
impôts veniant majeur à notre
compétitivité
notre monnaie est trop cher pour notre
économie bon / / / ça chacun s'accorde à
le dire mais le retour aux monnaies
nationales va permettre aussi de pouvoir
remettre la banque de france dans ses
prérogatives et autoriser la banque de
france a prêté au trésor sans intérêt
plutôt que d'être entre les mains des
marchés financiers qui demain je elle
restera aux mains des marchés financiers
c'est avec les jeunes et d'évaluer doute
encore plus cher non seulement parce que
le privé financera le privé et le public
financera le public or nous avons dit
nous lorsque la banque de france sera
rétablie dans ses prérogatives nous
monétisons la dette ce qui est un tout
petit peu en train d'être fait
d'ailleurs au niveau européen on trouve
ça très bien vivre et bien pas bien au
niveau national bon ben moi je dis si
l'un c'est bien l'autre c'est bien aussi
sur ses nous maîtrisons 5% du pib chaque
année le fmi a dit que à 5% on ne
demande pas la vue du ciel et or franck
de contrat et à la finance j'ai pas dis
que ça coûterait rien ça a d'ailleurs
été
ça a d'ailleurs été chiffré dans leur g
ça a été chiffrée je crois me souvenir à
4% du pib
mais ça va recréer de l'emploi mais bon
c'est très très bien a ajouté blanc et
le chômage monsieur n'était pas de
langues aimer grands messieurs avec les
chez moi je veux sortir de cette spirale
or aujourd'hui on ne remboursera jamais
la dette et vous le savez et tous nos
dirigeants le savent et il ya un malheur
c'est que aujourd'hui où nous sommes
totalement dépendants des marchés
financiers que va-t-il se passer si les
taux d'intérêt montent et bien si les
taux d'intérêt montent les 20 30
milliards de sacrifices que l'on a
demandé aux français seront rayés d'un
simple trait de plume
je veux sortir de cette spirale là alors
certes il y aura un légère
alourdissement mais il y aura un retour
des exportations
un retour nam est d'accord tout un
retour de l'emploi parce que moi
monsieur je veux bien tout ce qu'on veut
mais avec quoi actuellement vous
rembourser la dette
avec quelle création de richesse parce
que pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
croissance il n'y a pas de création de
richesse
il n'y a pas d'emploi alors on parle de
la justice s'il vous plaît maintenant
avec la crise un taux bien et qui a été
sévèrement uv dimanche à marseille vous
êtes pour le tout carcéral ça vous
l'avait bien dit je n'ai bien entendu
dans votre discours on est d'accord
chaque peine de prison doit être exécuté
il y en a cent mille qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui généralement ce sont des
peines de moins 2
deux ans dans combien de prison voulez
vous construire urgemment 40000 places
parce que 40 places de prison ça nous
mettra au niveau de la moyenne des pays
européens par rapport à leur population
urgemment 40000 places
oui bien sûr il faut les construire
aujourd'hui il ya soixante mille détenus
qui sont entassés dans 190
établissements
vous avez parfaitement raison et il y a
moyen de manière assez rapide de pouvoir
quand les peines sont exécutées il faut
plus que doublé en fait maintenant
monsieur on en campine et non car ce que
vous
ce que l'on ignorait probablement c'est
que dans ces cent mille peines il ya
énormément de récidivistes à dire des
gens qui ont déjà à leur actif même
trois caps 5 pen qui ne sont pas
exécutées d'ailleurs on voit ce que ça
peut donner dans le sentiment d'impunité
qui évidemment se développe à l'égard de
ces délinquants voix avocate il n'y a
pas d'alternatives à l'incarcération à
il peut y avoir des états unis en avoir
il peut y en avoir il peut y en avoir
mais je crois que ça n'est pas le je
pense que toute sanction doit être doit
être exécutée car si la sanction n'est
pas exécutée elle ne remplit pas
néanmoins le rôle qu'ont témoigné que
l'éloignement les probation dit il peut
y en avoir pour les primo-délinquants
par exemple il peut mais pour les
primo-délinquants une fois pour les
primo-délinquants on peut envisager par
exemple un sursis ça s'appelait bon le
problème si vous voulez c'est
qu'aujourd'hui grâce à madame taubira
n'est que la suite à la prison des lieux
que la condamnation ça n'est que la
suite non c'est la sanction la sanction
ça n'est que la suite de la fête de
l'impunité accordée par madame dati
aujourd'hui le sursis ne sera pas
révoquer automatiquement ça veut dire
qu'on va vous mettre en sursis mais la
prochaine fois vous venez vous aurez
aussi un sursis à la fois d'après vous
aurez encore un sursis moyennant quoi
c'est exactement comme si on ne
condamnait pas qu'avez vous pensé de la
phrase de jean marie le pen au sujet du
bijoutier nice à sa place j'aurais fait
la même chose d'assez son opinion c'est
pas la vôtre non moi j'ai pas envie de
me retrouver dans la cour d'assises
manuel valls a présenté à nice des
mesures qui sont réclamés par les
bijoutiers se disent plutôt satisfaits
on leur a parlé de la géolocalisation de
la vidéosurveillance deux rondes de
police plus fréquentes mais le ministre
d'intérieur est dit qu'il n'y a pas de
recette miracle
il est pourtant il faut du travail pour
vous il ya des recettes ni radio pas des
rosettes miraglia des recettes
oui écoutez c'est marrant parce que tous
les pays de le céder
vu baisser la délinquance et la
criminalité de manière massive et que la
france où ça augmente c'est donc
manifestement les recettes appliquées en
france ne sont pas les bonnes que celles
qui sont appliquées dans les pays mais
aussi d eux sont mieux à l'heure avant
d'aborder maintenant votre ambition pour
les élections municipales de l'an
prochain pour lesquelles vous lancez des
centaines de listes voyons comment vous
y prenez par exemple à boulogne-sur-mer
la ville du ministre féret cuvilier
avant d'accueillir à fela hermano de l'
agence france-presse
le reportage de paul bouffard qui s'est
rendu sur place vous êtes sur le terrain
bien sûr fait passer le message ce n'est
pas une réunion des jeunes militants fn
non antoine golliot réuni ses troupes
avant la bataille
à 28 ans cet ingénieur n'a pas de mal à
trouver ses quarante deux colistiers
avec toi j'ai romain tu seras un nouveau
co listiers pour la liste boule bleue
marine
donc je vais te faire remplir tout de
suite ce formulaire d'engagement dans
une ville ancrée depuis 50 ans à gauche
il est un de ces trentenaires à l'assaut
des mairies de france c'est une réalité
surtout notre électorat à une grande
partie de jeunes
d'ailleurs un dernier sondage montré que
36 % des jeunes voter front national
votre et front national que ce soit
d'ailleurs pour des élections locales ou
municipales et cette marée de jeunes
frontistes n'est pas du goût des
opposants à l'ump locale
c'est un jeune aussi qui s'engage mais
pour david dubois 27 ans la jeunesse
n'excuse pas tout le discours radical
est toujours là aujourd'hui en ce qui
concerne localement donc c'est monsieur
golliot qui a 28 ans et qui a comme
modèle monsieur haider je sais pas si
vous connaissez le néo nazis autrichien
mettre des jeunes pour mettre des jeunes
c'est bon c'est pas là c'est parce qu'il
faut faire et aujourd'hui moi je me
poserai la question marine le pen si
demain on nous offre enfin entre
guillemets la chance de la croiser
pourquoi avoir mis une tête de liste qui
a incommodé la nouvelle année aux nazis
à part la provocation
aux dernières cantonales antoine
beaulieu se seraient déclarés séduits
par le style de jörg haider à la mairie
derrière les hauts murs du bastion
socialiste on ne s'inquiète pas plus que
ça ce ne sont que des jeunes en plein
coup de com ils n'ont pas d'espacé
véritablement je veux dire de parole et
de
des tribunes donc les conseils
municipaux vont devenir des tribunes
pour ces personnes qui vont avoir la
l'occasion de pouvoir en découdre
peut-être avec avec les politiques je
pense que c'est surtout ça donc il faut
que tu sois un maximum présention c'est
important que les candides côté
électeurs que les électeurs et futurs
électeurs du front national
je vois sur marche dans la permanence
d'antoine golliot séances de coaching
avec le responsable départemental
on a un secrétaire général d'un
mouvement qui s'appelle steve briois qui
a une expérience et marine le pen
lorsqu'elle l'a nommé secrétaire général
a voulu de faire des mondes
or dupliquer la méthode partout en
france c'est ce que nous faisons ici sur
la commune de boulogne-sur-mer
aux dernières législatives le front
national a remporté près de 14% des
suffrages
nous avons d'abord sur votre candidat
vous donne donc le fait qu'ils ne soient
manifestement admiratif de jorg haider
vous choquer ce que 7e je croyais faire
leader est mort peut-être qu'il le
trouvait bourg manifestants ont pensé
non pas pour son physique mais pour ses
idées oui bon cjd excusez moi mais enfin
il a été au gouvernement je crois
pendant un assez long moment sans que ça
pose deux problèmes majeurs
marine le pen bonjour alors pour les
municipales en vue d'éventuelles
alliances locales vous proposer un pacte
qui rassemble toutes les autres
propositions comme je lis refusait
d'augmenter la fiscalité agir pour
assurer la tranquillité la sécurité
lutter contre les gaspillages
est ce qu'au fond c'est pas un petit peu
fourre tout ah non je crois pas non nous
nous avons dix points qui sont des
points incontournables ce n'est pas
notre programme municipal d'ailleurs le
programme municipal sera rendu public
dans une convention municipal qui aura
lieu à la mi novembre qui sera le
démarrage de la campagne de l'alliance
exactement ce sont les points que nous
considérons comme incontournable est-ce
que
l'arrêt des subventions aux associations
communautaristes c'est pour tous non et
pourquoi nous le mettons parce que nous
voyons que l'ump et le ps ont n'ont eu
de cesse que de financer les
associations communautaristes dans leur
ville pourquoi une production commune
autorise par exemple l'association des
je ne sais pas des portugais
associations comme c'est une association
communautariste oui la république la
république n'a pas à financer les
associations communautaristes nous lui
voulons lutter contre le communautarisme
quel qu'il soit ça ne peut dire que
l'association doit disparaître ça veut
dire qu'elle n'a pas à recevoir d'argent
public elle doit vivre sommes toutes
deux des adhésions de ses membres il
faut qu'une association répondre à
l'intérêt général et pas d intérêt
particulier le refus de l'augmentation
de la fiscalité pourquoi nous le mettons
pas ce que nous avons vu que dans toutes
les villes ump et ps
la fiscalité locale a explosé et donc
notre formation politique le promettent
également sur la fiscalité sur
l'ensemble du monde vous n'êtes pas les
seuls
d'accord monsieur mais moi excusez moi
mais je regarde un petit peu je juge
aussi un petit peu le maçon au pied du
mur quoi je m'aperçois que monsieur copé
nous explique qu'il veut une baisse
massive de la fiscalité mais il voulait
mettre la tva 24% et lorsqu'ils ont été
au pouvoir ils ont créé sous nicolas
sarkozy
plus de quarante taxe est augmentée de
30 milliards alourdie de 30 milliards la
fiscalité
j'ai tendance à pas le croire si on vous
pose la question sur ce pacte également
c'est parce qu'on n'y trouve pas les
marqueurs les fondamentaux du front
national par exemple quid de la
préférence nationale que vous vous
appelez priorités nationales pourquoi
elle et pas dans ce pacte mais l'epa
dans ce pack parce que pour l'instant
elle ne peut pas être mise en oeuvre
elle serait t'il légale et par
conséquent moi je respecte la loi
nous nous avons voulons mettre en oeuvre
la priorité nationale mais nous le
ferons en gagnant les élections
présidentielles
élections législatives au risque de
décevoir un peu votre électorat parce
que vous savez bien qu'à l'applaudimètre
notamment dans votre discours c'était le
cas à marseille ce qui marche c'est
aussi c'est quand vous parler
d'immigration quand vous souhaite à ces
critiques ont scandé on est chez nous
d'immigration en matière de sécurité le
maire a très peu pour voir monsieur vous
me conseillez quoi de violer la loi
non je vous demande en fait qu'est ce
qui fait l'identité de fondation des
sciences est constamment est-ce que vous
me conseillez de violer la loi non bon
donc on vient d'être fait parce qu'elle
était pétrole par exemple on doit
changer au niveau national tant qu'elles
ne sont pas changé nous sommes
respectueux des lois et par conséquent
nous oeuvrons dans la limite des lois de
la république qui sont certes
extrêmement imparfaite et que nous
entendons changé en gagnant les
élections présidentielle et législatives
mais il n'est pas le temps de cela pour
l'instant
donc on réitère pas l'expérience qu'elle
avait été menée à vitrolles quant à lui
une prime de naissance aux mères
d'enfants recensés aux européens c'était
un petit peu l'erreur qui a été commise
c'est qu'on a voulu faire de ces villes
par un excès de zèle d'une vitrine de la
politique nationale
et ça n'est pas le cas voilà le lit
municipal ce sont les municipales à
chaque élection ses spécificités
et oui effectivement on ne commettra pas
à nouveau cette erreur
donc le bilan ce le bilan des mairies
frontiste globalement vous le trouvez
vous dites c'était plutôt une erreur
enfin on pense à orange toulon je pense
qu'on est très injuste parce que la
réalité c'est qu'à toulon en tout cas
sur le plan des finances publiques la
situation s'est beaucoup améliorée je
vous rappelle encore une fois que jean
marc chevallier a été élu alors que la
ville était sous tutelle mais monsieur à
rex l'avait ruiné donc quand il est
parti ça s'est amélioré mais cette sorte
de volonté de faire des laboratoires si
vous voulez à mon avis n'était pas une
bonne idée nous nous en sommes rendu
compte et puis il ya quelques
personnalités qui ont dépassé dépasser
la ligne mais la différence et ça peut
arriver à tous les mouvements politiques
d'accord avec moi la différence c'est
que nous on les reprend pas ces gens là
voyez on l'aimé pas ministre alors que
les autres partis politiques ont plutôt
tendance à ne pas sanctionner leur ce
qu'ils ont des élus qui commettent des
erreurs que pour mémoire jean marie le
chevallier il a été condamné pour des
modes tournement de fonds publics quand
même servi comme monsieur ayrault
d'ailleurs qui est actuellement monsieur
premier ministre et qui a été condamné
il
lourdement sur le plan pénal n'est ce
pas ça ne l'a pas empêché de devenir
premier ministre
oui moi je mettrais pas jean marie
chevallier premier ministre ça peut vous
rassurer alors été blanchi pour monsieur
ayrault la peine a été effacée je prends
à mais ça n'empêche pas qu'elle ait
accès non mailhac ensuite
ah bah oui comme tout le monde à mon nom
au bout d'un moment ça sent du casier
judiciaire mais il n'a pas été blanchi
loin de là il a été condamné
définitivement et puis là bénéficié bas
somme toute de la disparition de cette
peine sur son casier judiciaire
l'iphone elle mentionné oui bien sûr
2014 concrètement quelle ville espérez
vous remportez hénin-beaumont bien sûr
mais lesquels un port bac avec florian
philippot béziers avec robert ménard
vous vous misez sur combien de villes et
combien de grosses villes mais je ne
mise pas voilà je ne lis pas s'exonérer
concernant un pari chaque ville gagne
est un succès puisque l'on n'a pour
l'instant aucune et je pense que nous
pourrions effectivement avoir plus de
municipalités que nous n'avons jamais eu
historiquement au front national
et puis parallèlement à cela nous font
élire des centaines de conseillers
municipaux vous savez que j'y attache
une importance toute particulière car il
s'agit là d'une implantation locale de
cette politique de proximité
cette politique de responsabilité de
preuve aussi que pourront apporter ses
conseils municipaux de leurs compétences
y compris d'ailleurs dans l'opposition
car si nous gagnons hénin-beaumont
demain c'est parce que pendant des
années nous avons démontré comme
conseillers municipaux d'opposition que
nous avions les clés
les solutions et la maîtrise de la
gestion d'une municipalité
il est notre ville qui est importante
c'est marseille on vous donne deuxième
pour le moment dans les sondages ça veut
dire que en gros vous allez faire
l'élection est ce que vous êtes prête à
donner un coup de main à la droite
locale
mais écoutez encore une fois nous
verrons tout cela si c'est pour donner
un mandat supplémentaire à monsieur
gaudin dont nous considérons qu'il a
horriblement mal gérée ciel gris
alors là mais vous ne savez pas vous
savez vous si ça monsieur gaudin qui
sera candidat on ne sait même pas encore
alors attendons ne soyons pas ce que
c'est que je trouve étonnant si vous
voulez danser municipal et dans le
discours ambiant qui est délivrée par
les adversaires politiques
c'est qu'ils passent leur vie à dire oh
là là le front national ils sont nuls en
gestion des municipalités ce
épouvantable ça va être épouvantable
mais s'ils considèrent que ça va être si
épouvantable alors pourquoi méthyle
autant d'énergie à nous empêcher de
gagner enfin de gagner qui nous laisse
gagner quelques vibrations monsieur
bruit comme ça et puis comme ça ils
seront tranquilles non la réalité c'est
qu'ils savent pertinemment que nous
ferons évidemment nos preuves et ce qui
les inquiète c'est que nous soyons dans
la calanque capacité de donner aux
français la preuve que nous serons
loyaux que nous respecterons nos
promesses et que nous améliorerons
concrètement la situation et la vie des
habitants
mais marine le pen justement qu'est ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui le fn est en
mesure de gérer des villes alors qu'il a
fait plutôt la preuve par le passé que
ce n'était pas le cas
qu'est ce qui fait la différence
aujourd'hui mais encore une fois parce
que je vous l'expliqué tout à l'heure je
vous ai dit que voilà il y avait une
peut-être une erreur de stratégie qui a
été fait aujourd'hui la situation est
différente
nous sommes aussi peut-être
professionnaliser nous avons fait un
gros travail de terrain gros travail de
formation et besutti à mon avis va
donner évidemment va donner ses fruits
et nous pourrons encore une fois à
partir le moment nous sommes dans laxe
de changer les choses mais au niveau des
municipalités et bien ne pas commettre
quelques erreurs qui ont pu être
commises dans le passé pour produire
peut-être un mois des européennes qui
viennent qui viendront derrière d'abord
est-ce que vous confirmez que vous-même
serai candidate
oui bien sûr je serai candidate dans ma
région qu'en est il de votre père il
sera candidate en paca d'accord est ce
que vous envisagez de vous associer avec
des souverainistes comme nicolas dupont
aignan ont dit qu'ils allaient donner un
coup de main à robert ménard à béziers
jeu nous avons monté le rassemblement
bleu marine
nous rassemblons bleue marine est une
association qui réunit des mouvements
politiques patriotes qui viennent
d'ailleurs de droite ou de gauche
si monsieur dupont-aignan considère que
la situation de la france est si grave
et si urgente qu'il faut maintenant
fédérer les forces
patriotique et qu'il veut en faire
partie eh bien il connaît mon numéro de
téléphone
on comprend pas très bien l'articulation
entre le front national et puis sur
rassemblement qui porte votre nom c'est
très simple le front national est un
parti politique le rassemblement bleue
marine est une fédération de partis
politiques voilà une fédération pour
présenter des listes communes en quelque
sorte de 2,2 de rassemblement lors des
différents salons dédiés à votre
personne donc puisqu'il apporte votre
prénom
non c'est pas entièrement dédié à ma
personne c'est c'était un clin d'oeil
qui avait été fait aux cantonales ça a
plutôt bien marché
les français s'en sont saisis il n'y
avait pas de raison si vous voulez de
leur retirer cette ce terme-là vous
inquiétez pas j'ai pas la tête qui a
gonflé elle n'est pas elle ne menace pas
d'exploser en n'ayant aucune inquiétude
sur sa si je tombais au culte de la
personne à lui n'en ayant pas du tout
pas du tout aux européennes toujours il
vous avez dit que vous pouviez faire
campagne avec un néerlandais qui
s'appelle gertwiller du parti de la
liberté à marseille vous avez dit que
vous ne vouliez discriminer personne
aucune religion en particulier lui en
revanche avec le coran il est plutôt
extrêmement dur il l'a comparé il a
comparé ce texte à mein kampf et il veut
même l'interdire aux pays bas il n'y a
pas une énorme contradiction non
monsieur garde ville das nous faisons
pas en france donc je ne veux pas les
campagnes avec mais je n'ai pas dit que
je ferai campagne et puis j'ai envisagé
jeudi que j'en vis je je je je pense
qu'il est utile que les partis
patriotiques européens se réunissent
dans un ce qu'on appelle un parti
politique européen
ça existe et le ppe pour la droite c'est
le ps pour la gauche
et nous nous avons un mouvement qui
s'appelle l'alliance européenne des
libertés dans lequel il y à des
mouvements qui sont des mouvements très
eurosceptique et qu'ils partagent mais
je les dis dans la même interview vous
pouvez pas l'ignorer
dans la même interview que vous citez
j'ai dit nous avons une sensibilité
différente sur ce sujet moi je ne lutte
pas contre une religion mais moi je suis
française et donc je suis tout imprégné
de la laïcité à la française que ne
connaissent pas du tout les pays bas ça
n'est pas dans leur culture ça n'est pas
dans leur culture politique et par
conséquent je n'essaye pas d'appliquer
aux autres ma propre grille de lecture
voilà mais il
comme monsieur wylder c'est un anti
union européenne comme nous que il en
dénonce les ravages sur le plan
économique sur le plan social sur le
plan de la souveraineté qui doivent
opposer qu'il est opposé une immigration
massive et anarchique que il est opposé
à l'islam est l'islam oui et moi je suis
opposé au fondamentalisme islamique
voilà c'est une différence entre nous
dernière question rappelle alors est-ce
que si vous êtes réélu vous continuerez
de rémunérer louis aliot comme assistant
parlementaire comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui nuit sera élu aussi par
conséquent il ne sera plus hélas mon
assistant parlementaire
je vais avoir bien du mal à le remplacer
je vous cache pas merci phénomène encore
internautes public sénat nous rejoint
avant cela
faustine saint geniès explore la
recomposition politique en cours autour
des milieux populaires et des classes
moyennes
travail production lutte contre la
précarité après l'insécurité c'est
l'insécurité économique qui est au coeur
du discours frontiste et dimanche
dernier à marseille
marine le pen a réaffirmé ses solutions
comme le protectionnisme ou encore la
sortie de l'euro si la tentation du
front national gagne certains
sympathisants ump
l'économie reste pourtant le point de
divergence entre les deux électorats les
deux électorats ne sont pas aujourd'hui
en osmose complète il n'y a pas de
fusion totale
il ya encore des différences assez
marquées notamment sur les questions
économiques et sociales
on voit que l'électorat ump demeure très
préoccupée par la dégradation de la
compétitivité de l'économie française
qu'il est très préoccupée par la
question de la dette et des déficits
publics
autant de préoccupations qui sont pas au
coeur des attentes et des sujets
d'intérêt de l'électorat du front
national
pourtant le discours de proximité du fn
séduit de plus en plus parmi les milieux
populaires et les classes moyennes
bien au delà du chant traditionnel
frontiste tout se passe à fait comme si
après avoir siphonné tout ce qu'ils
pouvaient s'ils me faune et au sein de
l'électorat ump et bien marine le pen
comprenez qu'aujourd'hui sa marge
progression se situer sur la gauche
comme la déception est forte dans
l'électorat de gauche est en partie d'un
électorat populaire la déception de
françois hollande bien c'est un
électorat qui devient captif pour pour
le front national
les laissés pour compte des partis
traditionnels se reporte ainsi vers le
fn le seul selon eux à prendre en compte
leurs problèmes
voilà perrine tarneaud est avec nous
pour poursuivre cette émission par une
passoire vos questions à marine le pen
aujourd'hui c'est la crédibilité
économique
non mais je crois que nous sommes
parfaitement crédible sur le plan
économique et un certain nombre et un
nombre de plus en plus important
d'ailleurs d'économistes rejoignent ou
défendre d'ailleurs sans le rejoindre
défendre les positions qui sont celles
du front national voilà et beaucoup de
français se rendre compte que le modèle
économique qu'on leur a vendu et qu'on
leur a imposé est un modèle économique
qui qui rend la france en faillite en
réalité qui est en train de tuer notre
modèle social et que cette compétitivité
dont on parlait tout à l'heure
plutôt que de la retrouver par
l'intermédiaire de la monnaie et bien on
est en train d'essayer de la retrouver
par l'intermédiaire de la déflation
salariale de l'effondrement du système
du système social par une politique
d'austérité dont je considère que c'est
une erreur majeure et presque même un
crime social mais pas le fn a revendiqué
le slogan de reggane l'état n'est pas la
solution l'état est le problème
est-ce que vous conservez cette réforme
est à l'époque l'état pouvait être un
problème parce que la france était
souveraine qu'elle était qu elle mais
qu'elle maîtrisait ses frontières
qu'elle n'était pas victime de la
concurrence internationale déloyale
aujourd'hui le problème c'est le
mondialisme c'est la concurrence
internationale déloyale c'est le le le
libre la libre concurrence comme ils
disent et qui est en train de ruiner
notre agriculture regardez le problème
aujourd'hui par exemple c'est l'accord
de libre échange avec deux lieux avec
les états unis qui va être un véritable
ravage pour l'agriculture et pour
l'industrie française qui a contrario
vous condamner la société de
consommation qui finalement nous pousse
beaucoup de ménages vers l'insolvabilité
mais non mais c'est pas le problème le
moi je suis pour une économie libre les
choses sont très claires
je crois à la libre entreprise je crois
d'ailleurs au génie français
moi je crois mais je crois à des
frontières je crois aussi à un état
stratège en faute et je suis au centre
en quelque sorte
sur le plan économique je crois un état
stratège je pense qu'on ne peut pas
laisser le marché tout faire je crois
que il ne régule rien qu'ils tuent par
ses excès par ces abus donc voilà je
pense que par exemple jeu contiendrait
je pense que par exemple l'état a quand
même des moyens de pression sur total
qui est en train de fermer l'usiné de
lusine de carn en mettant à la porte de
120 personnes alors qu'ils ont fait 10
milliards de chiffre d'affaires en 2012
voilà ce que je crois certains disaient
que monique finalement la même chose que
jean luc mélenchon c'est un peu
l'impression qu'on à cet instant précis
si on excepte non m côté l'immigration
et mu à oui mais c'est d'abord être
d'abord ces écoles comme vous dites
c'est ces deux côtés c'est très lourd
comme changement parce que on parce que
les mets migration elle sert justement à
soutenir la déflation salariale elle
sert à peser à la baisse sur les
salaires
et puis jean luc mélenchon il ne veut
pas de protectionnisme à nos frontières
or les français ils veulent un
protectionnisme à nos frontières ils
veulent que l'on recompte fois on se
lance dans la reconquête du marché
intérieur et que on protège les
productions françaises et donc les
salariés français de la concurrence
internationale déloyale
il n'est pas sur cette ligne là monsieur
monsieur mélenchon et c'est ce qui fait
effectivement deux énormes différences
entre nous l'assemblée nationale a
adopté la loi du flou sur le logement
qui instaure une 40 y est universelle
sur les loyers impayés est ce que c'est
une bonne mesure selon vous pour
protéger les propriétaires alors si je
vous rappelle juste d'une mesure qui te
dans mon programme et présidentielle
sauf que à chaque fois que les
socialistes se saisit de mesure il en
faut une machine à fabriquer les mégots
quoi c'est à dire que c'est baba c'est à
dire que ce truc là ça ne fonctionnera
pas et c'est triste parce que pas parce
que c'est ma utc technique mais c'est
mal fichu voilà moi je pensais qu
effectivement mettre en place une
garantie des loyers au même titre qu'une
garantie automobile pouvait être une
bonne idée mais à charge pour les 46
contre les impayés
oui mais à charge pour l'état d'aller
lui même se donner les moyens de la
puissance publique pour pouvoir
récupérer les
les sommes qui ne sont pas versées sas
avait un avantage c'est que ça
permettait aux propriétaires de
continuer à investir dans la pierre si
vous voulez sans avoir la crainte de
l'impayé qui parfois est dramatique pour
les personnes âgées par exemple pour les
jeunes couples et en même temps
permettre aux salons français de pouvoir
accéder à une location sans qu'on leur
demande la garantie de leurs parents de
leurs grands-parents de gagner quatre ou
cinq fois le montant de leur loyer vous
le répéter plusieurs fois en ce moment
et encore dans cette émission on s'est
professionnalisé est ce que ça fait
d'être vous ouvrez un droit d'inventaire
sur la d'années jean marie le pen
non ça veut dire que nous étions un
parti jeune et que par conséquent plus
comme nous sommes maintenant en
situation d'exercer le pouvoir
il pèse sur nous évidemment des
responsabilités encore plus lourdes que
quand nous étions un mouvement dont
l'objectif était déjà de briser les
tabous pour les mii pour mettre au
centre de deux des débats des sujets qui
étaient occultés par la vie politique
française
vous êtes tout à fait dans la continuité
idéologique par rapport à votre peur
donc oui mais c'est parce que ça veut
dire aller moi je fais pas d'idéologie
monsieur moi je fais du pragmatisme moi
je fais pas d'idéologie jeu pas là pour
défendre une idéologie je suis là pour
diagnostiquer les problèmes des français
il y apporter des réponses c'est bien
d'ailleurs pour ça que les partis
traditionnels ne répondent plus aux
préoccupations des français parce que
ils sont dans l'idéologie et même si la
situation change
même si ils se rendent compte de l'échec
des politiques qu'ils défendent
eh bien j'ai quand même si on avait deux
valeurs d'idées le comice sont dans
l'idéologie ils ne tiennent pas compte
de la réalité
mais non monsieur c'est quoi les mois je
suis patriote
j'aime mon pays je veux le défendre je
pense que partout en toutes
circonstances il faut penser à défendre
l'intérêt de la france et des français
avant tout si pour vous c'est une
idéologie
écoutez je vous laisse ça mais c'est pas
pour moi une idéologie c'est la vraie
pragmatique votre père raconte souvent
comme s'ils avaient qui est très vexé de
pouvoir en 2002 on l'a d'or
ici c'est ici oui parce que vous ne
tardez que de nuit voilà donc il a
souvent raconté que s'il avait accédé au
pouvoir en 2002 il n'aurait pas su chi
nommé notamment comme secrétaire général
de l'elysée ou comme premier ministre
vous nommez rien qui aujourd'hui je le
sais mais je vous le dirai pas ah bon ah
oui parce que c'est complètement hors
sujet voilà donc moi je le dire aux
français il y met un jour elle mais vous
le savez très bien vous en voyez quand
même vous voyez des tas de gens de
qualité autour autour de moi vous voyez
des experts vous voyez des amiraux en ce
qui concerne la défense
vous voyez des géopoliticiens c'est ça
la politique
la police ya six mois je vous le voyez
on voyait des il ya des économistes
vous voyez des gens vous voulez
peut-être pas les voir mais croyez moi
ils sont là et je les présenterai aux
français le moment venu
et d'ailleurs je les présente aux
français au fur et à mesure du temps qui
nous sépare de la future élection
présidentielle vous mettriez jean roucas
à la culture tu pas du tout sûr qu'il
ait envie de ça à marseille lors de
votre discours dimanche dernier vous
avez dit les hommes politiques inspirent
aujourd'hui le dégoût il est un peu dure
vis-à-vis de vous même
non je crois très honnêtement que ceux
qui nous ont dirigés et ça n'est pas mon
cas ceux qui nous ont dirigés inspire le
dégoût
oui les batailles d'ego les batailles de
personnes les bataille d'ambitions
inspire le dégoût français je pense très
honnêtement ne rien révéler en disant
cela je pense qu'il ne pensait y faisait
mais que les autres je pense qu'il faut
une autre manière de faire de la
politique je pense que tous ceux qui ont
fait des promesses et les ont pas tenus
des gouttes les français alors oui je je
je
évidemment j'envisage de faire les
choses autrement voyez-vous et de
respecter le mandat pour lequel j'aurais
été élu c'est à dire appliquer les idées
politiques pour lesquelles j'aurais été
les et respecter les objectifs que
j'aurais donné aux français
j'ai été élu pour faire ça j'ai pas été
élu pour faire l' inverse
nicolas sarkozy il avait été élu pour
réduire l'immigration il l'aggravé
françois hollande il a été élu pour
faire du social il fait de
l'ultralibéralisme et ils fabriquent des
impôts tous les jours voilà respecter
juste ce pour quoi on a été élu ça
paraît pas très compliqué donc la
gauchère
des français ce sont les extrêmes qui
les rassemble oui je crois je suis je
refuse cette formulation d'extrême car
je ne vois pas ce qu'il y'a d'extrême
dans le projet pour la france que je
présente je le trouve au contraire
extrêmement raisonnable et effectivement
je pense que c'est le seul capable
d'unir les français dans un grand projet
dans un grand dessein et d'arrêter de
voir les français en fonction de leurs
origines ou de la religion pour des
raisons clientéliste
les français sont des français ils sont
français avant d'être n'importe quoi
d'autre et l'objectif de l'état c'est de
leur apporter une égalité sans tenir
compte justement de cesser ces
différences qui doivent en tout cas dans
le regard de la delà de la deûle et à
être lisse et de question pour finir
j'ai lu vous vouliez supprimer le scénar
vous ne croyez pas aux mécanismes non je
n'y crois plus j'ai vraiment senti parce
que si vous voulez j'ai le sentiment que
le sénat est coûteux et somme toute à
part défendre ses propres intérêts en
refusant d'ailleurs de voter le non
cumul des mandats qui pourtant est
réclamée par les français est une
chambre de défense d'elle-même elle
allonge considérablement les procédures
et à mon avis comme je les dis dans
certains projets de loi n'ont bike ou
des non je crois parce que c'est peu
c'est pas obligatoire compte tenu de ce
que j'en vois ça me paraît être un coût
et un allongement des procédures
relativement inutile
marine le pen à ce que vous êtes pour la
pénalisation des clients de prostituées
et un rapport parlementaire qui le
recommande cette semaine et une
proposition de loi qui va être déposé au
parlement français je pense que c'est
toujours le même problème c'est le même
problème que pour le sait même problème
que pour le cannabis si vous voulez là
soit on lutte contre le cannabis et à ce
moment là il faut pénaliser les
consommateurs
si on veut lutter contre la prostitution
à ce moment là il faut lutter contre les
consommateurs mais je crois pas que soit
l'urgence
ouais je vous dis très fat très
facilement je pense que l'urgence
absolue c'est de lutter contre les
réseaux criminels qui se sont
développées au bénéfice il faut lui dire
de l'ouverture des frontières parce que
quand on n'a plus de frontières ben on a
plus de contrôle aux frontières
donc ça a entraîné une explosion des
réseaux mafieux et des réseaux criminels
qui se sont installés sur notre
territoire et contre lequel à mon avis
il n'ya pas de lutte sérieuse qui est
menée pourquoi est ce que les frontières
seraient ne serait pas synonyme
d'ouverture à vous nous parlez toujours
vous attaquez toujours les frontières
mais on se dit vous pouvez nous proposer
peut-être un repli qui serait mortifère
et pourquoi on a toujours eu des
frontières dans toute l'histoire de
france et on n'a jamais été dans un
repli mortifère les etats-unis ont des
frontières la chine a des frontières le
brésil a des frontières
tous les pays tous les sont ouverts sur
le plan économique au vous croyez ça à
lachine est ouvert sur le plan
économique mais j'ai pas eu ni surtout
vers ça me plains économique oui comme
c'est de rappeler leurs heureusement que
les frontières sont ouvertes en europe
on avait à offrir un débouché monsieur
comme sein de leurs apparitions
considère c'est là que ce prêt mais je
ne veux pas fermer les frontières je
veux les maîtriser et je veux décider
éventuellement de d'y apporter des
restrictions lorsque c'est notre intérêt
d'y apporter des restrictions si c'est
pas de notre intérêt est bien à ce
moment là on n'y apporte pas dans tel ou
tel domaine de restrictions on n'a pas
parlé de politique internationale marine
le pen vous avez dénoncé le belliciste
françois hollande
quels mots ce que vous utilisez ce
serait avec la dernière question pour
bachar el-assad dans le régime porte
bien la responsabilité de l'effroyable
massacre chimiques comme le rapport de
l'onu ans est fou si non c'est faux dans
le rapport de l'onu il n'y a pas de
responsable que tout soit pointé du
doigt le responsable est clairement
désignant les roquettes sol-sol seul le
pouvoir mais c'est foot c'est vous et
vous le savez les stocks de fusion c'est
faux et l'allemagne le dis que c'est
faux d'ailleurs ne dit pas la russie
parce que sinon on va me dire à poutine
etc
l'allemagne a indiqué à donner des
éléments extrêmement précis et vous
savez pertinemment qu'il y a des
arsenaux chimiques c'est madame carla
del ponte d'ailleurs qu'il l'avait
dénoncé commissaire à l'onu qui sont
tombés un poil mamans qui sont en moi
pour qui les mains des rebelles sais pas
ce que je dis je dis que je ne sais pas
en l'occurrence qui est responsable de
ces de ceux de ce massacre chimiques
même si je considère que les autres
massacres sont tout aussi terrible car
l'éventration par les fragments de
bombes
je sais pas s'il faut faire une
hiérarchie en l'occurrence dans
l'horreur mais je considère qu'il ya une
réunion
comment dire on a résolu
en tout cas semble-t-il par la voie
diplomatique le problème de ces armes
chimiques et tout le monde s'en sent
mieux et ça n'est pas grâce à françois
hollande
quant à moi ce qu'il dit puisque pour le
chef de l'état français la fermeté à
payer merci marine le pen la semaine
prochaine marisol touraine la ministre
des affaires sociales et de la santé
sera notre invité bonsoir
[Musique]